un ejercicio de estilo la declaración de
un programa
la primera ministra tiene previsto
revelar su hoja de ruta ante el
parlamento francés este miércoles antes
de esta prueba de fuego elisabeth box ha
tomado una decisión aunque el partido
presidencial perdió la mayoría absoluta
en las elecciones legislativas la
primera ministra no buscará la moción de
confianza una decisión defendida por el
nuevo portavoz del gobierno
generalmente la confianza se pide
posteriormente mostrando que somos
capaces con la mayoría de la que
disponemos en construcción y junto a la
oposición de aprobar leyes en el
parlamento esta es la confianza útil y
paul moses habla con souza y chile la
ausencia de un voto de confianza fue
denunciada por los diputados de nubes la
coalición de izquierda que anunció que
presentará una moción de censura aunque
tiene pocas posibilidades de éxito ni la
agrupación nacional ni los republicanos
se unirán a ella pero para la francia
insumisa se trata sobre todo de una
cuestión de principios y de democracia
son grosos
el significado de la censura es
obviamente marcar los que no votan a
favor de la censura están atrapados en
un golpe de fuerza contra la democracia
votar por la censura del votar que los
franceses en su mayoría no querían este
gobierno
en su discurso de política general se
espera que elizabeth box aborde el
primer reto del gobierno el poder
adquisitivo este jueves se presentará un
proyecto de ley en el consejo de
ministros a continuación se debatirá a
partir del 18 de julio en la asamblea
nacional